police in Pakistan are on high alert it
comes after the Pakistani Taliban
targeted police in recent weeks and
threatened the Prime Minister and
foreign minister
but in the province
it's the police who are on the front
line the militants have equipped
themselves with thermal sites on weapons
now those thermal sites are being used
by militants on guns sniper weapons and
they are targeting policemen at at night
time on rooftops of the police station
where they are guarding or on various
checkpoints but just days ago two police
officers and one civilian were killed
during an attack by the Pakistani
Taliban the situation has angered locals
who fear a return to violence they took
to the streets to voice their opposition
to the Taliban the threat is very real
the Pakistani Taliban released this
training video promising more attacks
and declaring its intention to impose
its Hardline interpretation of Islamic
law and its opposition to the Pakistani
military
psychologically
each and every person
uh
very very disturbed because of these
militancy like situation in life here in
KP kidnapped the people
receiving the ransom
threatening them targeting them
so the situation is very very alive very
very alarming
in the capital Islamabad there have been
warnings of possible attacks against
diplomats and foreigners
2022 so 150 attacks carried out by the
Pakistani Taliban killing dozens of
people one good thing that we have seen
in the recent past is that people of the
concerned areas like we must have seen
in swat and in waziristan where the
whole population irrespective of their
party affiliation they all got together
and they all protested and they showed
their resolve
for now there's hope authorities will be
able to deal with this threat and there
won't be a return to violence